I have a pet toad really yeah but mud in
a laundry basket in the kibble he was
big brother that is one of definitely
most lesbian things I've ever heard
somebody do that toad laundry basket
full of mud yeah dude no your daughter's
gonna be a lesbian you give her a
laundry basket did you put so much a mud
and a frog in it yeah it was interesting
for sure exhibit I realized he wasn't
having a very nice life so I let me go
um yeah I don't know I would never had
any pets man I got attacked by one shy
animals in our neighborhood growing up
but I was saying is I had a dream bro
that dude I barely got any sleep I had a
dream that Oh somebody was yeah
somebody's car broke down in my dream
right so I stopped to help out and the
dude told me it wasn't a dream
the person I stopped to help so now I'm
like [ __ ] so now you gonna help push
this gun oh I had to help I had to take
him wherever he had to go and then a
bunch of other [ __ ] came up just like a
bunch of just errands yeah we got a
nightmare oh dude I'm waiting on a dream
bro I was so stressed I'm waiting in
line prescriptions I bet no I don't
think I had that answering calls and
[ __ ] it's definitely a lot of stuff on
my phone I had to get do groceries how
to do all of that bro but I had to [ __ ]
this dude to only because his dude told
me it wasn't a dream so then I'm not
like dreaming I'm like like I'm busy you
know oh you dream man Oh [ __ ] that's
a nightmare son there's a nightmare
that's a nightmare it's very rare I
remember my dreams good or bad yeah I'm
very rare
I think that's bad dude I think that's
bad for your brain that's what they say
yeah do you ever think that somebody you
know didn't have brain trauma I've been
punched in the face yeah a little bit
but somebody said somebody sent me an
email that said don't say anything to
Brendan about his brain because he might
have brain trauma really yeah and I felt
bad about that actually
I'm not joking man whoever said that
weird thing it's all I got a brain I
don't know you don't see this for some
I'm not sharp because I thought or I've
CT or some [ __ ]
don't man [ __ ] to him cuz be here
triggering a flip-out yeah I mean that
was kind of thing so I felt horrible man
because I thought like you know I felt
no I don't have it configured all his
amore someone I was like flaring it up
you know yeah that's what I thought I'm
good I was like I texted due back I was
like when you look at Mehnaz he seem
like he's okay
he nice checked out good we go I don't
have any signs I don't I don't think so
yeah I don't think I do all this [ __ ] if
I did now I might get it down the road
it could get pretty nasty but do you
worry about that no I don't I I think
they say one of the best things you do
so because a lot of those guys are CT
and brain trauma stuff from football and
fighting is they stop like being
creative they stopped pursuing stuff
right then they [ __ ] because they're
not really using the brain then it's
much to begin with yeah but yeah is
there ever anything that happens it
flares up that you think like oh this
could be even a little bitty like a
moment every now and then or anything
cuz you know like I'll forget my keys in
like well here we go you know like all
right CT but this is your standard [ __ ]
right it's like you forget your family
on a vacation
oh no never been or you know when he
meets on like like oh hey this is Ashley
Mike nice to meet you Ashley
the turnout like how the [ __ ] is that
girl's name like here we go there's a
brain trouble man you asked for it man
you would [ __ ] ask for it was there
ever like a certain like hit or moment
or moment in football or fighting that
you're like oh [ __ ] that's gonna give me
some trauma I mean I've been knocked out
before really it's not healthy but in
football we would in practice and in
games I would know we didn't know at the
time how bad it was for E but we'd know
it's like I'd get like this ring and I'd
have headaches and [ __ ] as bad man
[ __ ] you never eating concussive
anything dude I got knocked out one time
I was looking for the remote and my
nephew [ __ ] pushed me down right I
mean I think I'm gonna got knocked I'm I
was a kid but I don't remember you know
you're a kid like everybody's knocking
each other out but as an adult I fell
and hit like my temple on Sunday yeah
bro and everything just kind of rattled
and then just went dark bro and then
next you know my brother was helping me
on him yeah you forget and I was like
what was that I thought I want to hit a
warp zone dude you know I thought I was
going to fight Bowser brought in Oh what
was that
Houser son cuz I've never just
everything just like you yeah it's like
slow motion and probably remember much
of it that's why I can't but ya can't
even fathom a that some of those type of
experiences you know that would kind of
make me not too worried about it
I get weary that's what I would I mean
it's one of the reasons I got out yeah
guys stick around too long they have
some big issues really [ __ ] yeah
hell yeah when you see my back ripple
and I pull myself up like a champ like a
champ through 30 times fast
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a gif it's a gift
it's a gift